[Applause]
two brothers who could not
have been closer but now it's claimed it
was william's snobby attitude towards
megan
early on that caused his relationship
with harry to break down
don't feel you need to rush this william
told harry according to sources
take as much time as you need to get to
know this girl
in those last two words this girl harry
heard the tone of snobbishness
that was anathema to his approach to the
world
congratulations from all of us within 18
months they were engaged despite
other mutterings about megan when she
arrived in the prince's life
one senior royal referred to the
american actress as harry showgirl
another told an age she comes with a lot
of baggage
and a high-ranking courtier was
overheard telling a colleague there's
just something about her
i don't trust they are more revelations
that confirm why the couple
felt cast out i think obviously being
part of the
royal family there was a lot of protocol
and red tape actually them stepping back
now that gives them much more freedom
to pursue their charity work and their
foundation so knowing harry's next steps
will be life changing not for himself
but
for those that he helps and i think
that's his passion that's both their
passions
christmas 2018 and the fab four were
putting on a united front
despite rumors that they'd fallen out
but the book confirms megan would agree
her and kate were not the best of
friends the sussex's spokesperson has
insisted they were not
interviewed by the authors they've been
very careful the authors
not to claim that they've had
interviews on the record interviews with
harry or megan
i suspect they well i know they've
spoken to them at some point
uh the extent to which they've spoken to
them
hard to tell but there's absolutely no
doubt whatsoever
they were introduced at some point uh
two close friends of theirs
and they have spoken at length to close
friends of theirs how does it feel
to be his best man it feels great
real and delighted honestly how is it
avengers
harry still asked william to be his best
man
but away from the smiles it's claimed
the couple felt constrained by the men
in grey suits within the palace
and undervalued for their star appeal
it's a kind of rather a whining account
and it's a bit inconsistent in places i
certainly don't think that it'll
damage the royal family but i'm afraid i
think it probably will damage the
sussexes to some extent
their mother's death inevitably made
them close and they grew up to be a
successful working team
it isn't clear if they've tried to patch
things up for one thing the two men
probably would agree on
they'd rather this private rift wasn't
playing out so publicly
rhiannon mills sky news